pool on the way
good evening members
welcome to this meeting of the audit
committee I'm now going to read out the
emergency evacuation announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the fire alarm activates please leave
the building in an orderly fashion via
your nearest fire exit the two fire
exits are through the partition doors
and through the main doors of the hall
or the storm adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is in the
roundabout Island in front of the main
entrance to the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
and could you please switch off your
mobiles or turn them to silent
and toilets and hand washing facilities
are available in the foia area
all right yeah members when I invite you
to speak please ensure you have one of
the microphones in front of you before
speaking as microphones are needed for
the hearing Loop and for the audio
recording these are all switched on
ready for you to speak so you do not
need to adjust them just please make
sure that the microphone is directly in
front of you before speaking
sorry no keep going I'll keep going
sorry members voting will be done on a
show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands
for and then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by officers
right my members item one agenda
apologies for absence
apologies for absence have been received
from councilors Mrs butcher council's
Mrs Laureen Shaw are there any other
apologies members
item two
substitute members
councilor Mrs Tony Carter is
substituting for Council Laureen Shaw
and councilor Mrs Joe McPherson is
substituting for councilor Mrs butcher
item three non-members attending
members we have none
item four minutes of the meeting held on
the 29th of September 2022 are the
minutes agreed members
Mr Mason Council of racing 28
. no chair and then do not agreed I
contacted member services
to advise them that on page two
paragraph three of the unconfirmed
minutes were incorrect
in that councilor Mrs Mason is
accredited as moving emotion when in
fact it was myself
yeah so
um
members in view of the uh Mr councilor
Mason's comment
where we um
oh yeah
but we agreed a minutes subject to that
being changed from Mrs to Mr Mason
bottom five to declare Declarations of
Interest
members are there any Declarations of
Interest
the agenda item six the audit progress
report for 22-23
members Mike Porter will introduce this
report
um since since the last committee
meeting back in September we have
completed a further two audit
engagements
um a review of the licensing
arrangements for a rockshire council and
also a review of the housing benefits
subsidy claim
um the licensing award is received an
adequate Assurance rating in relation to
this audit there are a few minor areas
for improvement
some of the web pages on the council's
site could be updated and now I've also
noted some delays where an update in
renewal dates particularly for mot and
insurance certificates and also as a
requirement for a privacy notice to be
published on the council's website in
relation to licensing Arrangements
in relation to housing benefits subsidy
across the sample tester there were no
errors identified for rent allowances or
the modified scheme there is one error
in relation to the process and the
benefit for temporary accommodation
where the benefit was understated by an
amount of 145 pound 59p
um as a result it's an understatement or
basically
um there will be no Amendment to the
housing benefits of the claim itself the
claims are only amended in relation to
overpayments of benefit
if I can ask members to return to
um 6.31 in terms of changes to the audit
plan
we were looking to undertake a review of
climate change this will now be
undertaken in 2023-24
some progress has been made in relation
to this area but not sufficient work to
Warrant an internal audit at this time a
report is going to the over overview of
the human scrutiny Committee in January
in terms of the next steps in this area
also included um or a minute added to
the to the um audit plan is the rest of
emotions for motions were noticed this
has been added and we wanted to take a
review this area in due course
coming back to
um
the audit plan and delivering the audit
plan
um we've still been unable to recruit to
the vacant posts we do actually have
interviews arranged for the 28th of
November and it's a hope that we will be
successful in implanting um a candidates
at that point in time
in the meantime we've also able to
basically secure the um
the surfaces of a third-party um
for a party to undertake audits um so
basically this company will provide us
of a number of audience they used to
help deliver the audit plan and it is
also hope to retain the services of this
party um for the fourth for foreseeable
future
in terms of counter fraud Arrangements
we participate in the national fraud
exercise every two years and we have
uploaded the relevant data sets in
relation to this exercise
uh council's Peter miles is the counter
for the compliance officer was the
finalist in the national awards
protecting an economic crime
in the outstanding category outstanding
investigator category um he didn't
actually win but he was a noted finalist
return to recommendations we currently
have 13 live recommendations
a total of three new recommendations
have been added in relation to the
licensing auditing audit
I'd just like to update members in
relation to a number of those
recommendations
recommendation two in relation to the
transparency code and creative
information that's now been implemented
also recommendation one in relation to
licensing is also being implemented
recommendation two in relation to risk
management degreed implementation date
for this was the 30th of November 2022.
this has now been pushed back to the end
of March
um so we can have discussions with
Brentwood Council in terms of the
arrangements
recommendation one in relation to
emergency teams playing in business
continuity
this has now been pushed back to the end
of December 2022. I'm quite happy to
take any questions in relation to my
report
members do you have any questions
remember is there no questions there are
three recommendations of paragraph 10.1
on page 6.2 of the reports
now the update on delivering the 2223
audit plan together we've revised audit
plan at appendix 4 be noted
that the conclusions and results from
completed audit engagements in appendix
3 and 3 be noted
and that the updated status of all the
audit recommendations in appendix 5 be
noted members are these noted
item seven
appointment of an independent member to
the audit committee members Naomi Lewis
the assistant director for resources
will introduce this report
foreign
so members will
obviously not going to hear a link
okay
it's not working
is that any better
I'll start and then if it's still not
working let me know no
okay
excuse me chairman would it help if we
swap places
Council Lawman would you like to sort
places with me to listen to this report
okay okay
and so members the purpose of this
report is to recommend
to full Council that an independent
member has appointed to the council's
audit committee from the start of the
next Municipal year in 2324 and this is
as recommended by central government
following the Redmond review and is in
line with set for best practice
um
just as a short introduction
um members should be aware that the
government response um earlier this year
to the local audit framework technical
consultation and set out a number of
plans to strengthen the local audit
framework and this was in response to
the Redmond review
and it did confirm that once
parliamentary time allows audit
committees it will be made compulsory
for audit committees and to have at
least one independent member required on
each committee
um as I mentioned this is in Leiden with
SIP for guidance as well um just to
provide a small further update on this
since the report was written there's
been a further sit for guidance that's
been issued and in that guidance they
actually recommend two independent
members
um however I think the the first step
for this committee would be to
um yeah recommend one member and then we
could obviously sort of um take it from
there in terms of whether we wanted to
then recommend the second member at a
later point in time
so I think it's kind of um yeah a timely
um recommendation to do to introduce
this now
um ahead of it actually being enacted in
legislation so that we are prepared for
that for that point
um the the the proposed
um uh
sort of recommendation is that the
um audit independent audit member would
not have voting rights on this committee
so they would be attending sort of
purely an advisory role
um so it wouldn't affect the balance of
the the committee in any way
um and the recommendation is that they
would be appointed for a two-year term
um and there is obviously further detail
in the report about the sort of a
specification of that of that member and
what they would be required to do but
the overall intention of having an
independent member is obviously to
provide that
um additional
um sort of expertise so we'd be looking
for someone that has particular kind of
knowledge and expertise in accounting or
audit so they could add that extra
um kind of expertise to the to the
committee's discussions
um
so I think the rest of the report is
self-explanatory there's obviously some
more detail in there but if anyone has
any
particular questions
um they would like to raise and I'm
happy to try and answer them
members do we have any questions
counselor Mrs Mason
thank you chair
um just a couple of points I'm pleased
to note it that the officer states that
it's a non-voting
situation we've had non-voting members
on standards committees for some
considerable decades there was a and
it's worked very well but I would like
to see that included in the report
because that aspect is fundamental and
it's not actually unless I've missed it
and that quality it is noted in the
report
um well I can't see it on the um
specification
um it's a power bar 3.8
so we put and got three points
all right okay that's fine and the other
thing that I think I'd like the
committee to consider is they say that
uh well the how will the candidate be
appointed and they're suggesting that
this is by the director of resources in
consultation with the chair of the audit
committee I think it would be preferable
to have that um appointment committee
widened somewhat to be a little bit more
inclusive but other than that I
certainly won't welcome this move thank
you
councilor Mrs Wilson
chair um councilor Mason has covered my
question in her second question in that
um just basically who will do the
recruiting for this then just open it up
wider because I think this committee
needs that
um
it's my new comment really
we've covered that if I'd have known I
wouldn't
okay um well yeah obviously it is a
matter for the committee I suppose to
advise whether they wish to recommend or
change a proposal to the to the
recommendation in terms of the audit
committee having that role in terms of
appointing the member obviously we have
had some sort of discussions internally
about the best way to um
uh sort of make sure we get the right
person and it I think it it was felt
from the monitoring office perspective
that um you know
having the chair sorry the director of
resources in consultation with the audit
committee
um chair was the kind of best way of
going about that but um yeah it's
obviously a matter for the committee if
they want to propose a slight amendment
to that as part of this report
councilor Mrs Mason yes if I could come
back on that I appreciate the officer's
comments but I think it's when we're in
a democratic situation and we're trying
to expand democracy effectively by
putting an independent person in I think
the whole process should be a little bit
more open and transparent and I do think
that one officer in consultation with a
chair is not a particularly open or
transparent method especially when we
have two appointment committees I'm not
suggesting that we use one of those
they're probably inappropriate but I do
think it should be expanded somewhat
um I'm quiet happier so how it's
expanded I haven't any particular
suggestions to make but I do think that
should be considered thank you
John
councilman
um chair it's a bit hard to make a
decision there's some clarity about how
it's going to be expanded so I don't
think that's something that lists
Clarity today that we can consider
[Music]
Mrs the councilor Mrs Mason did you wish
to make a recommendation well if we're
going to have to be
um
particular about it I would suggest that
certainly an office so the chair of the
audit committee and members two other
members from other groups or so that
you've got you've got a balance there at
the moment there is no balance
so is that a recommendation you're
making yeah I'm quite happy to make that
recommendation I'm quite happy to amend
it as well because I didn't expect to
have to be this specific I was just
concerned that the appointment system
wasn't as open and transparent as I
think this Council would like to be
thank you
I think this committee could agree on an
interview panel and who that would
consist of
Ambassador in the interview panel was
just basically the um the chair of the
audience committee and the head of
government insurance
um but yeah I don't see any reason why
this committee can't agree on their
numbers in terms of an interview panel
as long as the interview panel is not
not too large
yeah counselor Mrs Mason do you have a
second
yeah I'll say
if I can clarify that there's three
members of the committee including the
chair and an officer in additions that's
poor in total which I think is would be
very adequate thank you do any members
have any questions regard that
councilman Mrs McPherson thank you
thank you chairman
um
as the officer has mentioned that it
could come back to the committee would
it be advisable that once perhaps the
officer has spoken with the chair and
they've come to
a formula for the recruitment but they
come back to the whole committee to come
to bring that back
um how officers can make a suggestion
yeah yeah
um so I'm just thinking around the
logistics of timing because obviously we
want to have time to recreate this ahead
of the new Municipal year so I think if
it was to be delayed until the next raw
dick committee
um obviously that would um I think
that's not till March isn't it so that
would shorten considerably the amount of
time we've got available to sort of do
the recruitment so I think
um
from from an operational perspective it
would be preferable to agree
um yeah what the makeup of that
interview panel looks like now so that
we can progress that and obviously
report it back into full Council because
this will need full Council ratification
as well
yeah I think this seems to have a life
of its own
um but the clarity that this committee
would appoint
um
an appointment committee consisting of
the chair of audit
and two other members of the audit
committee and the directors of resources
of recommendation or any recommendation
members the recommendation put forward
is a new the uh it would be a amended
the interview panel would consist of the
chair of the audit committee plus two
members and the director of resource
members
do you wish to vote on that are those
four
against
any abstentions
foreign
that recommendation is carried there's
five four three against and two
abstentions
right members there are two
recommendations to the report
are you are you willing to vote on the
recommendation at the same time
but the second one sorry
yeah sorry sorry
yeah the second recommendation has been
amended as per councilor Mrs Mason's
recommendation
right members
the uh say there are two recommendations
the first is to recommend Council that
an independent member is appointed to
the council's audit committee from the
start of the new Municipal year
23-24 as recommended by central
government following the Redmond review
and in line when the Sip part best
practice all those members in favor
and the second recommendation is it that
delegates the recruitment of the
independent member to the chair of audit
with two plus two members from the audit
committee and the director of resources
all those four
against
oh sorry you know
the recommendation is carried
thank you members we now move on to
agenda item 8 review of the council's
risk register for 22.23 members Mike
Porter will introduce this report
um sorry chair I think that's actually
going to be me that one how's it outside
um thank you chair
um so this report is the regular report
that members of this committee receive
um it's a six-month review of the
council's risk register
um and members will know that the last
time this was presented to audit
committee was in July of this year
um
so the full corporate risk register is
included at appendix a to the report
and where it sets out all the key risks
that the council
um is facing together with the controls
in place to mitigate those risks and an
assessment of each whether each one is
considered to be high medium or low risk
um each of the risks is supported by
fully risk analysis
um that isn't published as part of this
report but we can make that available on
request
um so I just take you through a couple
of the the points um so paragraph 4.3
sets out the specific risks that have
been reviewed for this for this version
of the risk register we we review half
of the risks um during each six month
period
and also just to note that paragraph 4.4
that um although the asset delivery
program has always had its own sort of
detailed risk register which has been
reported on
um as part of the local Partnerships
Health review check they did recommend
that there was this kind of Standalone
risk around the asset delivery program
which was also included on the council's
corporate risk register so that has now
been added as a new risk which is risk
17 on the corporate risk register
um the the three areas sorry just moving
on to um section five the three areas
that remain
um assessed as having a high residual
risk um or as reported previously
um and they are risk 3B which is around
health and safety where further progress
has been made since the last audit
committee met in terms of additional
training provided to officers and
partners
um however there's still an element of
further assurance that the risk owner
Fields is required around consistent
application across the council and
that's why that that area is still
judged to be and have a high residual
risk rating and then the other two risks
um are also as previously reported so
they're risk nine are assessing a
balanced budgets
um and members will note that obviously
we the level of Financial Risk that the
council and other local authorities are
facing remains High
and then thirdly risk 10 is the ability
of the council to recruit and retain
staff and that just reflects the kind of
current market conditions
um and um sort of where the council and
other local authorities are in terms of
having difficulties recruiting and
retaining um staff but obviously that is
um partly mitigated through the
arrangement that we've entered into with
Brentwood where we obviously are looking
to
share staff across both authorities in
its hope that that will enable us to
recruit and keep keep those staff
um
so I think probably they're the main
areas I was just going to draw to your
attention
um that is ever if anyone's got any
particular questions they'd like to ask
then I would do my best to answer thank
you
councilor Mason
thank you Jim and I'll address this to
you but I think
um
the assistant director of resources will
probably best to answer it
um I I have forgotten
please excuse me
I don't know who actually reviews
the risk register is it purely the
assistant director resources or is there
a panel
I'll pass that question
um thank you so each corporate risk has
its own and assigned um risk owner and
they are responsible for
um updating and reviewing the risk but
ultimately I suppose it's the audience
committee the part of the audit
committee's function is to then review
and assess all the information that's
being collated to buy all the different
risk owners and as you have the
opportunity tonight to sort of challenge
or ask any questions so it's reviewed by
the risk owners also then at corporate
leadership team before it comes toward
it committee
thank you for reminding me thank you
are there any other questions
councilor Mrs Wilson
thank you chair mine is um more of a
comment than a question if that's okay
um I don't know if it will be helpful to
other members on the committee but it
certainly would to to myself for for
future agenda items for the risk
register might it be helpful for as part
of the agenda that the full risk
analysis is given for the areas that
have been looked at in the previous six
months
I understand a risk register and I
understand what goes on behind it but
with this particular risk register of Mr
gender and indeed the previous one there
was no background and I just found that
a bit difficult it would be helpful to
have the background on the topic that
that are being looked at or reviewed or
that are considered to be of importance
for for what whatever reason whether it
be health and safety or financial
yeah thank you yeah I think that's a
obviously a reasonable request
um so we can seek to provide a bit
further detail and background in terms
of the risks that have been reviewed I
think the reason there isn't a lot of
detail is such in the report is because
those risks haven't fundamentally
changed I think in previous versions of
the risk register where there has been
more significant changes we have brought
those members attention but because in
this case the the actual kind of
assessment of the risk hasn't changed
materially it's only been sort of minor
wording changes there hasn't been a lot
to bring to your attention but um I take
your point that we could maybe just
mention that a bit more in the report
thank you just to people like me who are
quite new to understand the the
background would would be really helpful
thank you
councilor Lawman
thank you chairman can you hear me
yesterday
um yeah thank you on the back of what
colleges has said there because I have
had mental questions over this you know
personal questions over this risk
register in that I understand where you
get your information from there but it's
the input of the information on that
register that I'm interested in
um and I won't get into detail but I
have had concerns about the 3B with the
food etc etc and some are current
with enforcement and for a year now I'm
still waiting for that result so where
would I maybe you could just advise me
and I'd apologize for not knowing what
I'm doing but where would I go to find
out what's going on and how I can come
argue or see so if I you say oh what the
rest is you know reasonable it's a high
risk or whatever you obviously get that
information from somewhere but how do I
access that information to check on
which is exactly what you were saying I
think how do I check on it that is
correct is that registered where do I go
to do that yeah I have a question okay
yeah um so I think as we know in the
report each corporate risk is supported
by a more detailed risk analysis and
just because of the each of those is
quite detailed in of itself and
obviously there's an about 20 corporate
risks and that would mean the report
would be you know extraordinarily long
and probably too long for committee that
you are more than entitled to ask for
that more detailed corporate risk
analysis that sits behind it and we can
provide that to members or you know to
the whole committee on on requests if
you'd like to see for example the the
risk the more detailed risk educator
that sits behind risk three three B so I
suppose you could either individually
contact the corporate risk owner or if
the committee as a whole wants to see it
then we can maybe seek on a rolling
basis to bring some of the the more
detailed risks I I don't think we'd want
to consider all of the detail of all the
risks at one time because it would be
too much but if there's particular
errors you're interested in we can
obviously seek to bring those back to
committee and also I suppose you are
entitled to ask the relevant risk owner
to actually attend the committee and
sort of explain if if you feel that
would be beneficial because obviously
I'm not the expert in in all of the
areas and of the risk register but if
you if you felt that's something you
wanted we could invite um the relevant
um director to come and sort of talk you
through that it's not it's not so much
I'm concerned sorry Joe and it's not so
much that I'm concerned about bringing
it to committee but as an individual
counselor I'm not even sure that there's
been a risk document raised you know
even though I've been in part of a
question so but my question really is is
how do I go and find that when you I
wouldn't expect it from finance and and
so on but where do I go to say because
I'm not even sure there's been a
anything raised on it that's how I feel
and so yeah so we have discussed that
risk in more detail at previous
committees but yeah on the on the risk
register the lead risk owner for that
risk is the director of assets
Investments so
um I suppose as an individual member or
individual you would probably want to
contact them in the first instance to
ask to see that more detailed or
obviously we as the um sort of lead for
risk management as a whole you could ask
me so either way we can we can get that
more detailed information to you and
then you'd have the opportunity to ask
any other questions I don't want to
bring it all up here yeah perhaps I
could talk about it later because I
don't know where to go for that
information
personally so anyway thank you chairman
councilor Mill
and responsible or other uh listening to
council Lawman's points
um
having some sort of familiarity in a
different sphere with this type of
approach to risk assessment
what we get is the summary
of the inputs from this format
um but inside a risk assessment which
gives you the numbers and the numbers
declare whether or not it's it's
tolerable the way through to to
highly likely to impact the organization
there should be documents for each one
of these they actually list what the
problems are if they come up during the
year so there's actually a record of
them that relate to the findings rather
than just the anecdotal collection of
thoughts because then you've documented
the whole thing and I presume we do that
yeah we do right and is that ever
available to be looked at or is that
just we just take it as a low medium
high in the summary yeah
um so sorry at the risk of repeating
what I've said already but there is that
there's more detail set in Pioneer so
this is a summary of the of the
corporate risk and but there is a more
detailed risk assessment which sets out
the individual areas of being assessed
and how they've been
um scored and obviously there is a host
of control kind of measures are in place
as well so in relation to health and
safety kind of risk as you said that the
health and safety officer would keep a
record of all um incidents or near
misses or whatever so there is
supporting documentation available it is
just for the scope of this committee
that we provide a summary but you are
more than entitled to ask to see that
detail there is a kind of monitoring due
diligence process as things continue
through which is yeah yeah that's just
nice to know because obviously because
we wonder how it all comes together you
know you would imagine perhaps you're
all meeting in a room and say hang on
we'll put this in so there is there is
some substance there's quite a lot of
detailed work that goes on behind that
and our risk officer who coordinates
this
um liaises with all the risk owners and
make sure that they they have reviewed
their risks regularly and that they're
you know keeping them up to date and
provide some challenge so that there is
quite a detailed amount of work that
happens behind the scenes to bring this
summary report to you yeah thanks
councilor Mrs Mason
thank you
check we're all um sometimes we get too
much information and sometimes we get
too little and obviously that's a matter
of personal opinion in all the cases but
I think the officer's comments were very
helpful in that where they are high it
would be helpful to have the background
papers
and at any time or very high I hope we
haven't worked for any very high
also I think when a risk moves up a
scale it would be helpful to have a
background paper but I do feel that if
we had the background papers to all of
this it would be unwieldy but on the
other hand I think
from the comments that uh councilor
Wilson Council Mill and Council Lawman
have made that that step would perhaps
facilitate a greater understanding of
all members and it would mean that any
questions that we have could be focused
more accurately rather than General
because risk is to an extent subjective
and with the best will in the world
someone's assessment might not be the
same as this committee's assessment so
it would be helpful I think to have that
and I think the officers recommendation
or suggestion of that was very helpful
thank you
are there any other questions
members there is one recommendation at
paragraph 15.1 on page 8.4 of the report
that the content of the corporate risk
register for 22 23 be noted members is
this noted
thank you members the time is now five
past eight and the meeting is closed